[Musique]
[Rires]
ceci n'est pas un appareil photo je lai
ouvert il ya deux jours exactement le
jour du réveillon de noël parce que j'ai
vraiment voulu pouvoir faire des photos
a titre perso j'ai pas forcément voulait
montrer mais en tout cas j'ai fait plein
de photos je fais plein de trucs avec et
au final ma conclusion c'est que ceci
n'est pas un appareil photo avant vous
dit réellement ce que ces jeux vous
ramener un petit pas en arrière je vous
montrais le déballage vous montrer ce
que j'ai reçu tous les différents
produits j'ai reçu et après il joue
vraiment vous donner mon retour
aujourd'hui on va parler photo ça c'est
un truc cool ça allait un premier dire
s'il ya pas très longtemps c'est la
marque le mot graphique qui nous
envoyait regarder ça ça c'est cool alors
lâché en train de tourner on né le 24
décembre 2018 c'est à dire que ce soir
d'ailleurs les rayons de noël jusque là
je pense que vous apprends rien à la
date où ça tout ça est justement l'idée
c'est de pouvoir faire des souvenirs
serait plutôt groupe on avait fait ça
plus dans monte un peu la tête
voilà c'est plutôt cool pendant les
fêtes de pouvoir faire des souvenirs et
justement je suis hyper content que
lomographie mais envoyer tout ça
simplement parce que je vais en profiter
ce soir pour shooter vachement de
souvenirs avec un appareil photo
instantanée avec un look un peu old
school donc je ne connais pas ce produit
de lomographie le nom instanz quare je
connais pas du tout donc je vais
découvrir
je vous montre un petit peu stagné la
boîte je vais sortir on va regarder
rapidement ensuite pas beaucoup et je
reviens d'ici quelques jeux vous faire
un petit débrief vous montrer quelques
clichés que vous allez mon vrai retour
soit appareil photo instantanée puis
vous dire si les coûts louis ou non s'il
faut l'acheter tout ça tout ça quoi
combien ou comment voilà qu elle package
alors qu'est ce qu'on a à l'intérieur on
a plein de trucs hyper cool
alors avant de regarder tout ça on
regarder directement
voilà ça c'est l'appareil alors comment
ça souffle ce truc
j'adore ce look un peu rétro ça fait
penser aux vieux aux appareils photos je
trouvais chinois chez ma grand mère l'a
pour l'instant je suis en pleine
découverte un gilet éviter de faire tout
et n'importe quoi avec
donc ça c'est l'appareil on a un petit
manuel d'utilisation on a un grand
manuel d'utilisation on a un mini manuel
d'utilisation spitzer s'accouplent
images j'ai du papier photo donc avec ça
je vais pouvoir shooter vachement de
choses vachement offrir donc ça c'est
hyper hyper hyper cool j'ai un autre
filtre
là j'ai encore un autre fils qui est là
j'ai encore les filtres j'ai un objectif
grand-angle
merci le mot graff us veulent également
de joyeuses fêtes de fin d'année
ça y est j'ai compris comment ça marche
c'est hyper simple pour l'ouvrir vous
avez juste à pousser là et ça l'a lu
directement vous avez votre petit visant
là vous mettez votre et l'avant garde et
ont déclenché vous appuyez sur le petit
logo
ici le mot graphie et ça vous prend
votre photo pour le fermer il faut juste
appuyer doucement sur la partie en basse
très mécanique 1 s'applique directement
là vous avez la mise au point là vous
êtes à l'infini et là vous vous
rapprochez et là vous êtes à 0,8 mais je
pense que pour faire un portrait il faut
se mettre directement là dessus ensuite
ce qui est cool est ce que ma fille lui
le mot graphie et franchement c'est
génial j'ai différents filtres voulait
positionner directement sur l'objectif
là j'ai un premier filtre la partie du
bas va être plus foncée la partie diot
va être un peu plus clair
un filtre à densité note ensuite je le
filtre étoiles pour le clip étoiles
c'est pour faire des photos comme ça ça
c'est assez marrant aussi je me rends
pas bien compte comme ça pourra vraiment
se rend compte directement avec les
clichés et là j'ai reçu une énorme boîte
avec plein de filtres différents
j'ai cinq filtres de couleurs plutôt
jaune plutôt bleu jaune à sa tête le
rouge orange pardon et rouge ça c'est le
grand angle ah ouais ouais la vache ça
c'est énorme
ne serait-ce que la halle a déjà posé
devant mon gh5 ça use davantage
regardez moi ce truc avec le grand-angle
ça vous fait un truc est énorme alors en
plus peut combiner parce que je peux
mettre le grand-angle et mettre en fuite
en rachetant le mal de choses donc là on
va évidemment sur un produit qui est
fait pour la création pour l'instant
tarik laisser ma quelques jours le temps
de prendre en main ce que je pensais
quand même pas mal de boulot et une
fente jamais triste bien on au repas et
je pense que là dessus il ya de quoi se
faire plaisir et en plus de ça clou du
spectacle vous avez une petite
télécommande qui vous servir à
déclencher à distance qui est intégré en
dessous en bas de l'appareil
j'ai vraiment hâte de l'essayer et je
pense que l'action à faire vos clichés
regardez comme vous êtes mignon ça c'est
magnifique ça au final c'est bien plus
qu'une photo et c'est en ça que ce
l'holographie le mot in stone skweres
est bien plus qu'un appareil photo
cet appareil est une fabrique à
souvenirs et c'est ce que j'aime avec 7
estrie appareil photo avec photo
instantanée alors très clairement c'est
complètement un parfait c'est très très
très imparfait comme appareil pour
régler votre distance c'est très
imparfait les clichés sont loin d'être
parfaits on est sur la photo instantanée
on n'est pas sur quelque chose de
magnifique connais pas cette chose de
lisse et on est sur quelque chose qui a
plein de défauts et c'est vraiment ses
défauts qui font cet appareil est unique
et qui font au final que ces photos
instantanées sont vraiment magnifiques
et que personne ne pouvoir reproduire
exactement de la même manière et c'est
vraiment ce que j'adore avec cet
appareil
en plus ce que je trouve génial c'est
qui la côte est qui est vraiment old
school il un look qui franchement
complètement incroyable vous devinez
appel que le logo ses deux boutons pour
appuyer ce que j'avais déjà testé des
appareils photos instantanées de type
polaroïd bon sur le principe fort que ça
cool on est sur le même système
il met le fait d'avoir testé ce mot
graphisme a vraiment donné envie de m'y
mettre d'aller bosser plus sur la photo
instantanée d'aller faire un paquet plus
artistique chacun y trouvera son plaisir
j'ai des amis qui lors de la naissance
de leur de leur fille avaient leurs
appareils lors lomographie faisait des
photos et ensuite avec leurs petits
souvenirs directement pris sur le vif et
ça c'était franchement aussi hyper cool
parce que le vrai problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui
il faut pas se mentir parce qu'avec des
appareils photo numériques ou avec des
smartphones d'ailleurs on fait des
photos on fait des photos fait des
photos on les stocke quelque part pas
toujours au même endroit il ya des
solutions pour permettre effectivement
de les mettre au même endroit des
solutions en ligne dans le cloud comme
google photos et consorts mais néanmoins
les photos on ne les a pas imprimé comme
on avait avant où on faisait des albums
un peu plus à l'ancienne mais malgré
tout c'est des objets vivants
c'est ça qu'on peut vraiment retrouver
avec ce type d'appareil alors vous êtes
toujours la possibilité de faire
développer les photos vous et ruiz avec
vous appareils numériques sais pas si
vous le faites mais moi je le fais pas
je ne fais jamais et c'est toujours un
petit peu les limites du truc du coup
pour visionner vos photos il faut le
faire à travers un écran et les photos
vivent beaucoup moins que lorsqu'on
avait des photos en argentique
on est développée et elle avait une
place plus importante dans nos foyers
c'est vraiment ça je trouve génial
avec ces appareils photo instantanée
c'est le fait de pouvoir faire revivre
les photos et les photos reprennent une
place dans notre quotidien
donc ceci les phases d'un appareil photo
ceci est bien plus qu'un appareil photo
ceci est une fabrication
et ceci est le moyen de faire rentrer à
nouveau les photos dans votre foyer et
croyez-moi ça franchement c'est super
intéressant
ce qui est super cool en plus de danser
que le mot graphie a pensé à tout a
pensé à vous dire on va vous aider on va
vous aider à prendre
améliorez vos photos à faire des photos
créatives parce que en règle générale
vous voyez votre appareil vous appuyez
dessus certains clichés c'est sympa mais
au bout elle est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus loin vous avez la
possibilité d'activer désactiver votre
flash vous pouvez augmenter votre expo
l'adc ci et ça et là vous avez le mode à
et le mode b et à vous avez un petit
retardateur et vous avez également un
autre mode de prise de vue c'est le
modèle x je vous la fais très courtois
qu'après il appartiendra à chacun
d'aller faire le type de photos qu'il en
soit plus artistique soit des photos
souvenir vraiment chacun fait ce qu'il
veut mais c'est ça qui est pas
intéressant et cette côte un peu
didactique en tout cas de ce qu'a voulu
faire le mot graphie avec son homonyme
times square c'est de vous donner plein
de photos pleines différentes photos qui
ont déjà été prises et sur ces petites
cartes vous avez d'un côté ici la photo
et au dos vous avez les réglages
là vous voyez une photo comme ça il ya
uniquement eu le mode à 2002 sussac
beaucoup plus créatif on a le mode mx et
le mode a mis dessus donc ça vous permet
vraiment d'avoir un petit guide au
travers de photos sans espèces de tuto
pour réussir à faire les photos vous
voulez et pour vraiment pas vous
approprier complètement votre appareil
parce que le lomographie l'aumône stand
square n'est pas un appareil photo c'est
un objet créatif et pour tous ceux qui
veulent se réapproprier la photo
analogique pour avoir vos propres
clichés à la maison c'est vraiment
génial pour moi le gros gros gros gros
gros point positif de cet appareil c'est
la créativité c'est l'analogique de
pouvoir complètement on vous
réapproprier vos photos mais à côté de
ça il a aussi des points négatifs
c'est très imparfait la qualité de
l'image est loin d'être top on est sur
la photo instantanée
c'est vraiment pas complètement
extraordinaire donc si vous voulez des
photos de belles qualités des souvenirs
qui sont complètement supprimée c'est
pas du tout là dessus qu'il va falloir
aller pour aller sur un appareil photo
analogique plus standard ou du numérique
et pouvoir faire développer vos photos
si vous voulez en tout cas les faire
revenir dans votre intérieur et le
deuxième
point c'est que les films coûtent quand
même relativement cher pour des photos
vous en avez pour 14 euros
c'est plus d'un euro la photo ça coûte
relativement cher et en plus comme c'est
pris sur le vif vous n'avez pas le droit
à l'erreur
vous payez photo vous prenez un peu plus
d'un euro vous jeter à la poubelle elle
l'appareil en lui-même coûte 239 euros
en plus de ça que je trouve vraiment
intéressant c'est fait d'avoir tous les
filtres d'avoir différents objectifs
pour vraiment aller complètement
exprimer votre créativité
alors au final acquise des styles se
lomographie install squared il peut vous
est destinée d lopp voulait un peu vous
réapproprier des photos et les faire
revenir dans votre intérieur dès lors
vous voulez pas uniquement des photos
qui sont dans un ordinateur ou dans un
smartphone qu'on ne voit quasiment
jamais dans le club mais que vous voulez
vraiment les faire revivre et les faire
vivre dans votre intérieur
je trouve vraiment cool le look est
complètement incroyable tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec à lesquels différents
mondes
c'est vraiment génial le prix est pas
complètement déconnant c'est un budget
sur 39 euros mais c'est pas complètement
ouf
maintenant vraiment le bémol mais
surtout les appareils photos
instantanées c'est la même chose le prix
des films reste quand même très élevé
c'est un choix on va pas chuter quinze
mille photos on va pas avoir autant de
possibilités de faire la même bonne
photo que sur un appareil numérique
néanmoins lorsque vous allez déclenchée
lorsque vous allez appuyer pour faire la
photo ça va être la bonne photo prise
bonne instant chaque cliché doit être
réfléchi on peut pas appuyer au hasard
ou alors à ce moment-là vous risquer de
gâcher une quantité incroyable de photos
mais c'est pas le but du jeu je sais pas
si cet appareil est fait pour vous moi
je trouve vraiment bien et ça me donne
vraiment envie de nous réapproprier les
photos d'en faire plein de continuer à
en faire et travailler là dessus et
surtout sur la création artistique
dites moi qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
que ces appareils photos comme le logo
graphie de l'ogc nice rennes scolaires
permettent de se réapproprier les photos
de rendre plus précieux chaque instant
lorsque vous allez déclenchée c'est
vraiment pour prendre le bon cliché au
bon moment c'est une vision de la photo
qui est vraiment différente de ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui avec du numérique
nous mettons ça vraiment génial
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire il vous invite bien
évidemment à vous abonner parce que vous
allez voir on va parler pourquoi pas de
différents types d'appareils photos
comme ça c'est plus intéressant et de
plein d'autres sujets autour de la tête
d'ici là soyez ça je vous embrasse et
prenez soin de vous ciao
[Musique]